the king of the Court LeBron James last
night LeBron broke another basketball
great Kareem Abdul-Jabbar's NBA scoring
record and the biggest stars in
Hollywood were right there to witness
history
James a shot in history
oh my goodness
King James's Sons Bryce and brownie
leapt to their feet as Magic Johnson and
Jay-Z winning for the hug all caught on
a hot mic
usher in a puffer jacket Denzel
Washington Woody Harrelson LL Cool J
celeb congrats coming from on and off
the court congratulations King James
what a legendary knife
no Adele but her man LeBron's agent Rich
Paul hit up the after party so did Kelly
Rowland without Beyonce after she became
the Grammy's goat
Queen B just posted this recap posing in
bed with bubbly and all her Awards
partying with Mom Tina Kelly and lizzo
and getting her groove on with Jay as
for her album of the Year snub Jay tells
title magazine he's never confident
going into the Grammys quote I remove
myself from the process and hope they
just get it right album of the year it
has to be as for benefits Awards
aftermath
Jayla was just spotted heading into a
dance studio wearing leggings that read
my voice is heard this as this Grammy
seat filler revealed benefis viral
moment was the couple actually realizing
sad Ben was taking over social media we
took the rock seat because he had gotten
up the rock turned to us and said you
better not talk to them that's kind of a
joke JLo handed her phone to Ben and
said hey honey look at this meme that's
circulating about you oh they were so
well aware during the Grammys about it
she was texting people about the meme
and sending it to her friends he just
laughed it off
[Music]
foreign